le fonds souverain de la norvège tient
de plus en plus compte des risques liés
au changement climatique de puits d'eau
2012 le plus grand fonds souverain de la
planète a liquidé 240 investissements
dont 140 sont liées aux risques
climatiques selon le responsable de la
gestion des risques au fond des
questions environnementales domine
beaucoup les discussions le fonds
demande d'ailleurs aux entreprises
d'être beaucoup plus transparente et le
canada devrait faire passer la taxe sur
le carbone à 210 dollars la tonne d'ici
2030 pour atteindre ses objectifs de
réduction de gaz à effet de serre c'est
la conclusion de la commission de
l'éco-ptz fiscalité du canada
actuellement la taxe s'élève à 20,23
dollars la tonne c'est 300 ennemis sur
le litre d'essence à 210 dollars en 2030
viendra ajouter 40 cents au prix du
carburant selon la commission les autres
solutions coûte plus cher et risquent
d'être moins efficace se dit à d'autres
solutions quand même et il ya notamment
l'investissement responsable qui peut
participer à la réduction des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre hervé guez est
notre invité les directeurs de gestion
amiraux va qui est une filiale du géant
d'investissement natixis
monsieur gaz bonsoir bonsoir niro va
consacrer à 100% aux investissements
responsables
oui exactement nous avons créé la
société en 2012 avec l'idée qu'il y
avait une tendance de fond dans la
finance qui était dire que la finance
pouvait être un outil utile pour
développer une économie plus soutenable
et qu'à ce titre là il était important
de développer pour des investisseurs
institutionnels mais aussi les
investisseurs particuliers des solutions
d'investissement qui permette
concrètement de participer à la
transition vers une économie plus
durable et donc concrètement on investit
dans quoi dans quel type d'entreprise
vous investissez alors c'est les types
de pros de classes d'actifs dans le
côlon proposons différentes ça va des
actions cotées donc c'est des actions
thématiques sur lequel on essaye de
privilégier des des entreprises de
solutions environnementales donc ça peut
être des entreprises actives dans le
solaire comme force là ça peut être
désactive des entreprises actives dans
l'éolien ou l'efficacité
énergétique ou nouvelles introductions
en bourse à laquelle on a participé
hoffmann green cmt qui propose un
procédé de ciment verre innovants voilà
donc des solutions environnementales des
entreprises bien positionnée sur les
enjeux de développement durable
ça peut être des fonds obligataires dans
lequel on va beaucoup privilégier les
obligations vertes et notamment par
exemple l'émission en 2007 de la
province du québec qui a émis une
obligation verte
et puis c'est aussi des actifs non cotés
donc des projets d'agroécologie
d'agroforesterie qui ont des impacts
directs par carrie permettre une gestion
saine et durable des sols est ce qu'on
est capable de mesurer est ce que vous
le faites
l'effet sur les gaz à effet de serre les
effets environnementaux de ces
investissements responsables
alors vous voyez bien que selon qu'on
est sur des actifs réels ou sur des
actifs qui sont déjà existants et qu'on
finance
la contribution est mesuré de façon
différente donc quand on est sur des
actifs réels on mesure concrètement sur
des sols on peut faire un carottage dans
le dans le sol pour vérifier que la
qualité du sol continuent de s'améliorer
dans le temps et reste et reste
soutenable
quand on est sur des actifs cotés des
actifs cotés en bourse
ce qu'on mesure on va mesurer chaque le
bilan carbone de chacune des entreprises
dans lequel on n'investit à la fois leur
impact sur l'économie puisque sur sur le
climat puisque toute activité humaine et
toute entreprise à une activité un
impact négatif si on veut en termes
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre mais
ce qui est important c'est qu'au s'il ya
beaucoup d'acteurs qui développe des
solutions et on essaie de mesurer leur
impact positif et donc pour chacun des
investissements qu'on fait chacune des
solutions d'investissement qu'on fait on
s'assure que nos stratégies sont alignés
avec un objectif climatique cohérent
avec celui que l'on sait donner à
l'accord de paris un objectif du maximum
de degrés et un objectif de réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
exactement le gros le grand message
c'est il va falloir basculer vers un peu
moins d'énergies fossiles
si je schématise pour faire un peu plus
d'énergie renouvelable et l'efficacité
énergétique parce que quand on regarde
les grands portefeuilles du monde
adhérents parler des fonds des fonds de
pension des fonds souverains
la grande majorité de ces fonds là ont
des investissements qui vont mener dans
les faits si ça se poursuivaient comme
ça à une augmentation de cas
35 degrés celsius ces deux du
réchauffement de la planète c'est quand
même incroyable
c'est une tendance ce qu'il faut
effectivement corrigé c'est que beaucoup
d'investissements se sont fait se font
de plus en plus en suivant j'allais dire
un peu aveuglément les grands indices
que vous commentez d'ailleurs
régulièrement mais qui sont
effectivement le reflet de l'économie
un peu passé et il est important que on
regarde aussi ce qui se développe en
dehors de ces indices
quelles sont les nouvelles solutions
innovantes et comment on ne suffit pas
aveuglément on ne repose pas tout
l'effort de transformation de l'économie
sur les entreprises qui sont dans ces
indices mais qu'on a une allocation
capital plus efficace et qui permet le
développement de nouvelles solutions
est-ce qu'il faut donc investir de façon
plus radicale est ce que de s'éloigner
de ses indices traditionnels qui nous
mène à 4,5 degrés celsius de plus pour
revenir à 1.520 objectif de paris est ce
que c'est un changement radical
d'investissement alors c'est en grande
masse c'est pas si radicale que ça si
vous regardez des grandes masses
économique on aurait besoin
globalement on a financé dans les vingt
dernières années si je schématise à 70%
des énergies fossiles et à 30% des
énergies renouvelables efficacité
énergétique on en est aujourd'hui à 50
il faudrait faire 30 70 dans l'autre
sens le problème c'est que dans un
indice traditionnelle bien souvent la
partie énergétique qui est cotée elle
pèse environ 10% d'un indice et elle est
quasi exclusivement composés d'énergie
fossile donc le balancement de
portefeuille qu'il faut faire pour aller
vers une économie vers des indices ou
des fonds à 5,2 degrés serait d'abord à
minima 5% à 10%
l'investissement dans des énergies
renouvelables l'efficacité narrative
autres c'est le camp très significative
effacés alors ça c'est des choix à faire
qui sont pas que des choix d'ailleurs 2
deux positions climatique investir c'est
faire des choix
les grandes tendances de fond aussi
l'investissement responsable je pensais
porter ce message on peut pas juste dire
que l'investissement s'est acheté un
indice et quand une entreprise rentrer
dans l' indice l'acheter quand elle sort
de lundi cela vendre nous nous
positionnons dix ans nous faisons
déchoir et les choix que nous faisons
sont d'aller prioriser d'aller investir
d'abord dans des entreprises qui
développent des solutions de même qu'un
gérant fait un choix par exemple
d'investir dans des entreprises
canadiennes
on lui demande pas si il veut à tout
prix exclure toutes les entreprises qui
sont pas et canadiennes de son
portefeuille
un gérant qui fait un choix de
philosophie d'investissement croissance
où ils demandent pas si il veut que les
entreprises qui sont pas dans la
croissance disparaissent des indices
donc il est logique et il aimait attendu
je pense par les épargnants que
l'investissement afin qu'un responsable
fasse effectivement c'est une offre des
solutions d'investissement différentes
merci messieurs guest pour cet entretien
ce soir c'est un sujet mal quand il y en
a beaucoup